this is a production of Cornell
University
you thanks a lot thanks for this
wonderful introduction and and I of
course want to thank you for that great
opportunity it's for me an honor to be
here I didn't expect so many people that
there's still a queue so either the food
is good or there's something interesting
in the top I do want to highlight that I
made seven versions of this presentation
down from should I show very specific
scientific results because I'm in
Cornell kind of the one of the the most
important universities - should I go
brother and show everything we do so as
I took finally decision and you may like
it or not but that's that's the decision
version it would be for a next time to
go broad - basically as this is a
six-year endeavor
I think I took the decision to show you
everything we work on so that you can
connect and see where are their
potential collaborations that means I
will not go very in deep in any of the
topics because it would not give me the
time and it also means that there are
others standing behind each of the
slides so every slide is not me on my
own every slide represents people within
CIMMYT that do the work but that are
willing to collaborate with each of you
and are willing to set up collaborations
that also means that in the future I can
go and give some more in-depth
presentations and seminars on specific
topics so you can ask your hummus for
the next next time that I come around to
give those more particular topics I also
want to say that the work here is done
because I'm standing on the on the
shoulder shoulders shoulders of giants I
don't know if you can is already here if
not he will he will probably arrive I
guess he's lost somewhere we will find
him but Ken Sayer was my PhD supervisor
and mentor and he happens to be here at
the same time so I'm I'm very grateful
for the following those examples also of
course Romney or for everything you have
contributed and many more here when I
first other disclaimer when I talk about
CIMMYT Internet
Mayson wheat Improvement Center yes
Macy's corn for those of you that doubt
about that the when I talk about cimmyt
I don't talk only about the institution
I talk about symud and and that includes
the network of institutions around that
so I try to put a couple of logos of
those who contributed to this
presentation of all those partners that
I've contributed I made a second one and
then I stopped but just so you are aware
that this is not a presentation of symud
as an institution this is a presentation
of the result of a whole network of
institutions and also I want to remind
several of you that the US should be
very very proud of this collaboration
and I want to especially highlight it in
the times where we are I had the honor
to discuss with Secretary of Agriculture
Purdue couple of weeks ago and to
receive your vice Secretary of
Agriculture that makini and they both
use this phrase and I liked it the most
successful bilateral effort between US
and Mexico so they saw symud as dad and
especially because of course of this guy
who's Norman Borlaug was the only man
that I still know that has saved 1
billion lives from famine by applying
science to agriculture and of course you
know everything about that and if you
don't be aware you have the best source
here sitting front row which is Ronnie
coffin which is the still the first and
only PhD student of Borlaug in that time
so I am NOT going to today but Borlaug
did because you have a way better source
than I have I do think what he also did
was not only saving 1 billion last he
set up an institution but it's which is
similar same it has offices in 13
different countries projects in 40
different more than 40 different
countries which are the green ones on
the map and we work with over 300
partners but the impact goes beyond the
countries where we have projects and to
not in order to not only pick on the US
Australia for exam
ninety-five percent of all the wheat
grown in Australia comes from the
network of research that is done in
Opera gone that is done in Albert and in
Mexico through the wheat research
Network so today I think we have to be
aware that there's three conversing
challenges climate change population
growth and limited natural resources we
are already using 1.5 earth in order to
feed the population if that population
is going to grow its projected that we
if we don't change we will be using 2.5
earth by 2050 and we can debate I'm not
going to go into it but yes climate
change is going to affect what we are
doing and how we are doing it so you
probably have to do produce more with
less and especially to eat better
number one this is a similar crisis as
the one Borlaug had the capacity to
listen to this is an invitation that we
all listen to carefully to do today's
crisis and barak formulated a response
today we need to formulate a response
which has to be equally transformational
but it's not going to be the same
response as Borlaug Development I know
I'm talking about more and this may be a
little bit misleading I think this is
what we have been driving ad during the
past centuries doing more more efficient
faster but we didn't really look at
resilience and I became aware of that
after discussions with Lloyds of London
and we asked Lloyds of London do you
realize what the impact is of a food
crisis is that in your models of
insurance and they said no because we
have no idea how food crisis is work so
we came together with a group and we
develop scenarios in which we basically
took five events that happen to past 20
years and we said what would happen if
you put them at the same time in the
same year can we develop a scenario that
paints that just too
be clear a scenario does not predict the
future it is very difficult to predict
especially the future so don't try to do
that it gives you an option it gives you
a scenario it gives you a thinking frame
to see what may happen so we worked
through this scenario we talked to the
the hotshots at Lloyds and we said look
what would happen if we put those five
events together which is basically a
ug99 impact if that would if that kind
of an event would repeat if we would
have a linear which means droughts from
one end of the world and floods at the
other end and if we increase temperature
what would actually be the result of
that so we did all our fantasy scenario
work and huge workshops multiple
stakeholders and we came up with this it
would mean 7% of global production loss
for wheat 10 for corn or maize 11 for
soybeans so many asked us whoa whoa whoa
whoa but your scenario was only about
weed that's obviously if wheat prices go
up farmers decide to substitute other
crops so you get impact on those so we
only look to it of the lens of fear when
to Lloyd and Lloyd said thank you very
much nice work we don't care so we went
back and we said can we translate this
in economic value can we translate it in
price hikes so this would mean four
times price increases for those
commodities and five times for rise when
back to Lloyd's Lloyd set thank you very
much I hope you enjoyed the work we
don't care so we calculated further down
we said this won't lead to humanitarian
crisis food riots and a drop in the US
stock market of 5% in the EU stock
market of 10% Lloyd said I hope you
enjoyed we are very interested obviously
because insurance is sitting here very
important but also we learned from that
that we could use it actually as a
leverage because that means now that
food security or food shock also it's
very important for a business continuity
electricity was already one of the
factors insurance would look like for
business
look at for business continuity grain
grain production for a Kellogg's and
Nestle was not something that was on
that map it was equally important as
post-its and paper clips that changed
with this and I will get back to that
later on I do want to highlight an
unsustainable global food systems Rd
compelling force and source for
migration so if we want to do something
about migration we have to develop
working a great food systems in Central
America in North Africa that is why if
we want to respond to today's crisis
it's gonna be an integrated aggregate
system approach which yes looks at food
security but especially at nutrition but
at the same time it has to guarantee
that every food system that it has a
certain circular operation so that we
can safeguard it I don't believe in the
opposition between conservation and
agriculture if we look at it as a
landscape system those two need to be
integrated and last but not least and
actually I put it first human security
human and national security so I'm
convinced that resources for agriculture
research for agriculture interventions
should not only come from USDA should
not only come from USA they should come
from the military they should come from
the health sector because if we
calculate the billions of dollars that
go lost in insurance in health care that
we could prevent through working our red
food systems giving the right nutrition
it's a huge amount of money and a huge
return on investment so you are smart
students here somebody needs to do those
calculations somebody has to put this
picture together and show it's not
enough to just say we know we need to
show it to those decision-makers of
those investments so for that
to integrate public and private sector
small medium and large scale farmers
that stop with the discussion if it's
large-scale medium small is the
integration and the resilience you built
through diversity and research
development and markets connect them in
order so we can build an enabling
environment transforming the secretary
into a sector of change innovate invest
in alliances and support at the same
time be individual so yes we need
Applied Science but in real time in
firewood farmers we also need innovation
and technologies but we need to put them
together in innovation systems and make
sure the public policies and enabling
and so this was similar with improved
varieties today our response has to
include multiple other aspects does that
means if it has to stop breeding no does
that mean some it has to stop building
pillars of excellence in sustainable
intensification no we require those
pillars of excellence but we also have
to put them together in an integrated
fashion so we can respond to a systemic
to our systemic response so to take the
journey same it safeguards the
biodiversity of macing with tasker also
many many thousands of farmers do in
their fields and that field institutes
in situ conservation is complemented by
a big team bank with 150 thousand seat
samples of wheat and 28 thousand samples
of mix why I'm not showing this I'd be
honored to lead a big investment owned
by the Mexican government which is
called masa grow it's around 20 million
dollars a year depending on depending on
the circumstances and one big step was
to characterize the gene bank and
Cornell has participated in that and the
first maze Atlas was announced in Cup 13
in Cancun and we're today working on the
wheat Atlas and many several departments
here supported with data science and
with analytics and with in order to have
the critical mass to do this
this dream bank is this important for
the u.s. yes it is this is a map of what
the seeds or the the samples or how you
want to be entries that are sent
throughout the US to multiple
institutions yearly so from this seed
bank packages are sent to multiple
institutions in this country in the same
project that we do in Mexico with masa
grow it the next step and we said if you
have the breeding part and you develop
new seats you may see it and you don't
have a vibrant seed sector it is not
going to work so we set up a
pre-competitive space where seed
companies are working together sharing
data integrating the data we started
with 40 seed companies today we have 70
small holders small seed companies many
of them are actually farmers coming
together and taking the next step
towards a business when the project
started in 2010 75% of the market was in
hands of what back then was pioneer
Monsanto and the other big ones the rest
was in small holder companies today
thirty five percent of the market is
served by this group of companies with a
focus on center and south of the country
while do I highlight that this is bigger
a bigger agriculture
this is smallholder agriculture so those
big companies are still focusing here
you're still making the same money the
pie hasn't become smaller money-wise the
pie has grown by serving this area here
which was unserved and the con
Sept was to bring those companies
together not to compete but pre
competitively share data integrate them
give them methodology and they do
compete obviously in the market and you
can see that this is this is the number
of new hybrids introduced by the seed
companies and their portfolio of
products for the large companies for the
medium and the small large this is the
large Mexican company so that's still
very small compared to the to the big
multinationals and you can see that from
masa grow started in 2010 so you can
suit 2008 this was the status quo should
be very very low in the small ones then
in the mid 2012 to 2018 2012 it takes
time before you rep ramped up still very
low but then since 2013 three years
after the project started data were
exchanged trials were out there this is
what happened and this makes it easier
for farmers to access those products
obviously also a Mexican government
invested in wheat and so there is a they
were the first investors in the wheat
yield consortium and obviously there's
the whole wheat yield network with
multiple
other donors that release new high
yielding wheat lines obviously
collaborate with rust initiative and
just one number for every dollar
invested in wheat research worldwide
hundred dollars is a return on
investment
bad news is if you're gonna put $100
here you're not gonna see it back now it
goes to farmers it goes to so it's a
social return is this important for the
US why am i putting those slides here
because that were the questions your
Secretary of Agriculture was asking me
all the time every stylist but yes but
is this important for the u.s. yes sir
it is
40% of all Breeders varieties come from
simit 60 worldwide 60 percent of all US
wheat rye arrived from cement and that
is obviously a contribution to well
being of wheat farmers in this part of
the world this is not
enough if we want to transit transit
agriculture from a threatening sector
that threatens well-being and nature and
a sector that is being threatened by
climate change changing pad climate
patterns to a responsible sector where
we apply what the crop requires and
where we have resilient systems to to
weather we need to also not only change
the seats but we need also to change the
practices and the whole system around it
so that means you have a couple of
principles that we are looking at can we
diversify crops can we reduce soil
movement can we look at soil surface
cover which would be conservation and
conservation agriculture but you have to
put all the other appropriate elements
probably you have to rethink the whole
system but I will get there so I'm
taking you to a thinking pattern but we
had to go through so we looked at long
term trials seemed it had a still very
successful long term trials very well
managed so if some students wants to
come and do what I did
I saw the trial the only can was only
measuring yield so I decided to measure
soil or soil health for that and I had a
fantastic and messy thesis and very good
after why it wasn't of me it was because
this was just a goldmine right if nobody
measured twenty years of different
practices whatever you measure looks
good even if it if nothing comes out it
looks good so have a good thesis just
these are the yield results of those
trials so you can see conservation
agriculture green on the top what
farmers are doing is blue and then if
you do thing all everything wrong which
means monoculture zero tillage and you
don't you end up from medius was already
quite a huge message be careful when you
talk to farmers and when you sent out
one delivery messages if I would go out
and say to zero tillage and the
traditional practice of the farmer is
actually monoculture conventional
tillage and taking away the residue and
I would only stress the tillage part I
would drive him to the red
I have to stress you have to also leave
residue and do crop rotation so if the
farmer forgets that one elements it can
be pretty tricky this is for maize for
we for corn means for weed you can see
the differences are similar but they are
less drastic at the beginning as
everybody knows which is a more noble
crop than maize start separating
I was actually very frustrating when I
arrived at that point that was around
when I finalized the PhD came as a
postdoc and I remember can say yes but
we have those long term prize but it's
not going to the farmer it was actually
Borlaug coming to Oregon and said I mean
last trip in his wheelchair grabbed my
arm and said you have to take it to the
farmer and I'm saying you gave a
wonderful presentation in front of the
long-term trial but and he didn't use
nice words all the time so he's
something like I don't give a crap with
this you should take it to the pharmacy
if you can so that means that we need to
set up a system where this basic
research can be entered so that the
knowledge can be taken up that was our
first idea we could
changed that and said no actually we
need a system where this knowledge can
be used and we get questions back so
that we can fuel our research relevantly
we can get new ideas from farmers we can
incorporate those new practices so the
system we developed was say can we
develop research platforms throughout
the country with local universities with
the local research centers but with a
similar protocol that are connected to
all farm on-farm
modules where we can compare practices
the
connected to areas where farmers just
and then you scaling so you have impact
areas where multiple people adopt so I
forgot I actually made the zoom so I
repeat quickly it's a research platform
modules where you do side by side
farmers implemented technology and then
things should go off and this set up
obviously is you need to set up for a
specific agro-ecological zone but
connect the different Iraqi illogical
zone so they're still learning also
there so I'm gonna give you the example
of Mexico but we have examples in Africa
do you want to have examples we have
examples in South Asia sisa I think you
some of you may know Andy McDonald he
has been instrumental in putting that
project there so there's similar efforts
going on that we can look at and on the
top you need that's not enough this is
infrastructure on the top we need a
learning network that connects
institutions farmers extension service
governments buyers that we cannot put it
together but can we also map it and can
we also use it what's the big question
so step number one the research
platforms today every point or every
doctor how do you call it every Square
every triangle on this map is such a
research platform so we have over 50 of
those platforms
that look at the particular situation in
the particular Agricola G but does dude
use very stringent science-driven
methodologies this is farmers come and
visit farmers give ideas but the minute
it's it's scientists managed scientists
operated with input from the farmer so
this is the controlled Empire but it can
look as controlled as this now I mean
it's nicely laid out but it is it is in
a safeguarded area but that doesn't mean
if there's huge infrastructure and what
were the results conservation
agriculture in Yucatan which is the
south of Mexico conventional agriculture
conservation agriculture conventional
agriculture in Chiapas another one in
Chiapas but in irrigated areas another
one in San Luis Potosi other way around
here water management is not about
getting a lot of water in it is making
sure that you don't get too much
solarization around so later the
graziano scientists conventional
conservation agriculture so this is just
a couple of pictures to show what is
coming up
obviously be careful am I saying here it
always looks like that conservation
agriculture is always better no I chose
a couple of pictures of what is
happening in those platforms so you can
see that there is share knowledge really
specificity yeah obviously lead guilt is
not enough we also need to look at costs
cost structure and obviously profit so
you can see here if you use some of the
conservation agriculture practices you
can have get higher profit higher
benefit cost ratios and you can go under
if you don't do two other practices so
you have to go also to the economic
return economic return it's not easy and
it it behaves very different as yield
you can see this in this map this is
like the dots of those multiple
platforms and it's very difficult
together but this mapped here these
production costs and grainy so there is
not an easy cutoff point to get out here
so it's gonna be specific for each
obviously you want to have the highest
yield with the lowest cost know you
would like to want to be so you have to
go back one of these dots here run but
at least now you know where you can go
and look and see what what is this cost
driver what has happened why is this not
working and it is not one practice it is
a practice a decision in a context that
is defining this the other obviously is
production cost and net profit somewhat
related but not hundred percent so while
doing this the British from simit came
back and got very worried because they
were you promoting CA but nobody planned
CA so is there gonna come or
conservation agriculture is there gonna
come a point on which you're gonna come
back to me and say all your varieties
don't work because now the world has
conservation agriculture so I said well
okay relax let's look at it first before
we panic so questions where does limit
provide appropriate varieties food
conservation agriculture benefits
certain varieties developed under
conservation agriculture practice
and is there a negative effect if
breeders all of a sudden would do
everything on their conservation
agriculture but they would also save
costs their breeding would maybe also be
more amicable with the environments so
step number one we took 27 wheat
varieties 13 durum 13 bread we'd put
them six cycles under conservation
agriculture fully irrigated review and
drought conventional irrigated and
drought those lines were released over
time so we had some weeds from between
the 60s and 70s all the way up to 2000 a
little bit before 2010 that's release
dates and they were released to farmers
in that area so what you can see here
for bread wheat
good news for the breeders yes there is
progress independent of the system
progress has been you do see that
conservation agriculture you do t
obviously a fully irrigated is lying
higher those two here then reduce
irrigation right and you can see some
slight differences that conservation act
lying a little bit higher than the
conventional but not huge differences a
little bit more differences for Europe
there's a whole paper about it we can go
in details I'm sorry I cannot zoom in
more for those who are interested when
we showed that the British said yes but
all those wheat varieties have been
developed under conventional practices
would there be a difference if I would
do all my breeding process on their
conservation agriculture practices so we
talked with curry mama and he started
this was huge project we did parallel
selection hard
under conventional conventional cea
started with the same input and see
where this would be driving huge work to
end up with those two graphs again I
know I'm going over it too fast but if
you look at it and you know a little bit
what is here doesn't look very I mean a
lot of work and not them not too much is
coming out I mean if there is there was
not a big separation of those two
greeting of the result of those two
breeding persists
this is what what did came out was
there's no negative effect of selecting
on the Reg even villages the Lecter on
the zero tillage did slightly improve
early vigor
but it didn't translating yield so good
bad I don't know
discussion for where's the maybe that's
how if you look at early figure as an
important point for some good best
practices in some of what you are
looking at maybe this is important if
you reduce seed rate and yield of lines
from poets election stream was higher in
zero too much testing environment so you
could go to breeding under zero tillage
keep some money be better for the soil
that that's what this research would
suggest in Oregon okay maybe in other
areas this is different I just can tell
you this is huge research to do because
keeping the selection separate testing
the MA doesn't of plot so it was a bit
frustrating to do not get really
something out but that's how that's how
research works the other side of the
coin for some people sitting here what
happens with soil quality so soil carbon
after nineteen years we do see zero till
where you keep the residue has a higher
soil carbon content especially in the
zero so whomever wants to look at carbon
cycling microbial whatever is huge
playing garden here we said camp disease
very I know these are rough data but can
we average the twenty research platforms
can we look what happens with CA
conventional tillage in all those
different environments and we did see
under conventional under conservation
agriculture zero to five centimeter
carbon content did increase five to
thirty centimeters it increased but last
there is more deep data down there next
step only Mason wheat is not going to do
it can we diversify so we can optimize
weed management so I see some wheat
people here and there are people that
get all excited about weeds so there is
some research that we are starting to do
can we do conservation agriculture is
this only higher herbicide driven no
we don't use GM let's be very clear this
is not round up all those systems I
should have probably said that before
all those systems are not Roundup Ready
amazed or whatever No
so some research on how to diversify for
wheat management do cover crops have a
role to play into this when we looked in
Mexico all cover crops eat was more than
40 years old no new research on that so
can we revisit research on that for
certain purposes that we didn't know it
would have had in the past that was not
enough if you do that how do we get
farmers to adopt if they don't have the
right implements and you're talking
about smallholder farmers we cannot give
them the big John Deere
the tractor is bigger than their plot so
we started an effort with looking at the
right machinery all open access so any
blacksmith building plan so that they
can replicate it more interestingly we
gave them iPads because people are
visual we learned out we found out not
many people know how to read these so we
learned from the pokemon hype and we
basically have now an app where you
click you put it on top of the machine
and how the machine should look like
pops up in 3d what is it called I don't
know the right name like the virtual
whatever like a pokemon pops up and it's
a machine so you can you can move it
around so for a for the blacksmith
that's a visual comparison instead of
this is very complicated it's a 2d
drawing of a 3d reality and you I'm very
comfortable with that but that's not how
reality looks like it's a representation
of reality and we can do better to data
now and then we learned from some of the
efforts also from an excellent here of
Cornell the whole what is it called
hello tractor uber for tractor service
to farmers is there something we can do
with that I missed
the project I was very happy that the
donor allowed me to put in a line that
said and this activity is activity
number Z everything you need to do to
make the project successful and we put
the budget so the last activity in the
whole setup was and anything you have to
do to make the projects luckily we did
that because we hadn't thought about
post-harvest imagined that so we have
thought of a lot of things and not about
post-harvest smallholder farmers lose
40% of the harvest that maize grain post
harvest so today we work on those post
harvest technology and if i say we work
that means that every dot on this map is
a farm driven experiment over 2,000 of
those experiments side-by-side
comparison of cover crops conservation
AG post harvest over 10,000 extension
areas this means farmers applying those
technologies and us harvesting the data
and over a million hectares of of those
innovations implemented by 500,000
obviously citizen science became very
important farmers are sending data to a
very big database and we are using those
data to send recommendations back to the
farmer but also to the Mexican
Statistical Office where we are showing
if they are making or not progress to
the sustainable development goals so we
use those same databases downstream but
also upstream not a lateral
communication and communication networks
are extremely important I know you guys
have some Network experts in your
different team so I think there is
something here
to look at this is just one of those
networks we have those for each
community for each state and obviously
we know who this is but does this mean
if you want to get the message out talk
to this
same effort to talk to this one is not
gonna yield the same success now this is
also pretty dangerous for two reasons if
you put the wrong information and this
guy believes it it goes out very fast if
you put the wrong information here not
that dangerous that's why you need
quality control mechanisms like the
platforms like that whole set up so
wrong information does not go out and I
embrace this doesn't don't call it
different you can also imagine second
danger at some point some very smart guy
came to me and said can I have this map
for the state of Oaxaca what do you want
to do with it I mean the theme of the
campaign of the governor was smart we
didn't give him the data or the name so
you need an open space but also a safe
space for some of those data cornell can
play that role limit him play that role
but we have to think about it this whole
system that we put it together from a
lens is too complicated for me this is
social sciences that put together a lens
of knowledge management what does this
mean for new knowledge management
concepts so you can see types of
knowledge processes of knowledge it's
defined in time space and in actors a
whole publication about that very
complex but it just want to show this
that there's a whole life laboratory of
500,000 farmers in Mexico we want to do
the same in Africa you have such a
laboratory already running in South Asia
I think about it you can we can do it
all that obviously what was the impact
this is a simple graph but NASA I will
start in 2010 this is the average yield
at level of Mexico for a range fed place
and we're very happy that we could earth
change the curve after this and
especially that the dots are closer
together I mean this is not under
present scientific a--probably have to
do another impact study but at least if
these already looked bad I would already
feel bad and I'm not saying he's hungry
percent attribution symmetry by essence
if you set it up as an innovation
network attribution gets diluted I mean
no this is not hundred percent similar
so don't come and ask me can I do an
impact study can I attribute it to see
MIT no you can't because it is a network
so attribute it to the network that was
not enough we didn't talk about who was
going to buy the grain extra grain it
will disappear somewhere automatically
no yes in some areas yes because farmers
would eat the grain additional grain for
self-consumption
but that doesn't take you out of poverty
so next question was can we put together
markets that actually respond to that so
we started some this is a this is a
slide from the World Economic Forum
so some models can we aggregate farmers
can be connecting to markets we did that
with small holder farmers so if you go
to you take the bus Friday and you go to
cosmos and New York City that they serve
blue tortillas that are bought from
smallholder farmers of this farmer net
because they want to tell a story now
you're not gonna save 5 million
smallholder farmers buy cosmos
restaurant no it is nice it is good it
is important but it's not going to
change the system safe so we asked
ourselves can we talk to Kellogg's
Nestle bimbo groomer and others so we
went to talk to them and I said I do not
want to talk to your corporate social
responsibility person nice guy but I
will drink coffee with him I do not want
to talk to your sustainability person
unless that person comes together with
whomever is at the core of purchasing
the grain because I want to talk
business continuity I want to show you
the Lloyds report to see what we can do
because those come
we're bringing in a ship and I apologize
to Iowa farmers they were bringing in a
ship of grain from Iowa which was easy
for them to clicks on the computer but
we wanted to ask them is can you
actually the extra grain that you will
require for selling more can we start
sourcing it from small holder farmers
that's an extra cost for the company so
now that easy their purchasing system is
not set up so what was the extra value
we were gonna get so what we did is we
set up a system with indicators where we
showed that actually the company can on
the one hand diversify the supply so
that generates resilience and on the
other hand five more minutes and I'm
finished and on the other hand it can
tell a story to the farmer to their
clients or to the consumers but it also
helps us with adoption why this is the
kind of graphs we sent to the farmers
now this was the farmer sustainability
evaluation Green is good yellow is bad
somewhat barren red is very bad before
he was connected to this market this is
a year later he's sustainability
evaluation because he can see it and he
gets a value for it because the the
purchase the guy that buys the Green
said yes but I will only buy it if it's
sustainably produced
so we use the same data to respond also
to the companies but also to send
farmers recommendations how can you move
through scenarios not to one point
change this or do that
scenarios how do these colors to make it
ready for market all our projects today
F online dashboards so any investor
donor can go online and can see how many
farmers trained how many woman yield
increased automatically automated
dashboards from those data sources so we
asked what is the next step when
elections were going to come and we
thought this is the right moment to put
forward what is the future of maize in
Mexico we asked three questions where
are we where are we heading if we don't
do anything and can we do it better so
on the where we are Mexico needs thirty
six point five million tons and it
produces thirty four to twenty four
point seven if you don't do anything by
2030 it will require forty six tons and
only produce twenty and we asked
multiple stakeholders 150 different
people are you happy with this outcome
if they would have said yes that's the
end of the story right nothing more to
do people that we are not happy can we
do because we don't want the demand to
increase we 26 in the production only
with 15 and we don't want to have a
deficit of seven point seven million
tons you already have one of 12 so that
we did an exercise multi-stakeholder
with this design transformational
scenarios we put scenarios forward and
we designed for self-sufficiency for
drivers of change and for a meal public
and well-being so it's kind of the more
self consumption of maize safeguarding
biodiversity some other drivers because
that is not the same group of farmers
there's a book about it in which we
describe the objective short medium and
long term actions expected results by
2024 and under each of these their sub
actions identified and validated same
thing for me pub universe and well-being
and this would put on the table of the
presidential candidates when the
president took office the president of
mech of Colombia joined him in the
discussion and in a five minute
discussion President of Mexico those
guys did something interesting with
mates maybe you have to look at it I
only need one phrase so we went by and
the President of Colombia said oh that
looks interesting
follow up with miss my Secretary of
Agriculture so we did when you talk to
president just one sentence is required
for fraction so we took that one
sentence I went Secretary of Agriculture
said the president said I need to sit
down with you and I need to do it so we
did mase for Colombia 2030 vision same
exercise where are we can we come to
agreement with all the stakeholders
where we are where are we heading if we
don't do anything interesting research
piece you can make it as complicated as
you work run models climate change model
also predict for 2030 how complicated
you want to do it depends on how much
brain power you have available make
scenarios for a better future you can
make artistic scenarios so some of the
art sciences would actually come in here
so same exercise we did that we
connected it with the SDGs and today we
have been asked to replicate it for
Kenya Pakistan Bangladesh and Ethiopia
and it gives a road map it symud going
to operate all of these no of course not
there's gonna be elements yes there's
gonna be elements no but it could be
good for Cornell to look at this
document if you want to do something in
Mexico or in Colombia so I told you the
story from the biodiversity making
better varieties setting up the seed
system making sure that farmers can co
develop develop climate resilient
production systems incorporating other
crops so they can Co design with
different sustainability technologies
here we need to make sure we can scale
it up with the right Extension Service
with the right support to farmers that
will generate grain surplus that needs
to be connected to local regional
national markets so we can reach the
consumer which can be a far reach over
in this so I
think sim it started here today we
realize we need to do an integration of
those pillars of excellence in
integrated programs that respond to the
sustainable development goals I want to
thank all the donors that have
contributed to this one story there's
multiple other stories of those
worldwide how improved see the adoption
of improved varieties is a big driver in
this strategy however what I think is
always interesting when looking at seed
adoption is like whom do the seeds serve
and I think it's racing and breeding to
see how farmers participate and while
we've seen some improvements in terms of
like integrating farmers into research
strategies there seems to be a lacking
sense when it comes to that and plant
breeding so what does submit do in terms
of integrating farmer strategies and
their breeding program yeah good
question and it depends I mean we are
working with farmer communities that do
participatory breeding with maize kind
of one one activity we are incorporating
farmer vision preferences for for the
kind of material they are looking for
same with industry at the same time and
this may be a bit controversial but I
also think we you need to be careful not
everybody has to do everything it's a
bit like I mean I call it always know I
didn't invent it but there is the
concept of t-shaped skills you need
disciplinary skills and you need
integrative skills and some people have
a very short t good a good strong lack
breeders could be so you want them to be
disciplinary methodological repetitive
and a short integration others have a
short I don't know I don't know how to
do it in my hand but a short no and a
bigger integrative capacity you need
both but don't ask somebody with a short
roof to be
sudden integrity maybe that's not his or
her skill that doesn't mean that we
don't have to involve farmers but I
think we need to involve them at the
right point so nobody gets frustrated
earlier on you mentioned getting all the
different companies on comment
encouraged yeah we made a lot of
mistakes it was very complicated he's
showing by doing and the most important
thing was trust one of the mistake for
example we may be callin finally on
board we said okay why don't you test
the material of your neighbor we we will
blind it so you don't see which is what
you sent the data out to submit and then
seem it will and then the next sentence
when a sim it will analyze and will send
the information back negotiation drops
everybody opted out they said no way
we don't want Seema to do the Anna
analytics we have analytics capacity my
neighbor doesn't have the same capacity
that's my competitive advantage
send me the data so today at the same
time same date same minute everybody
gets the data and then what you do with
that data is up again in the comments
but at least for me that was a mistake
to say we will analyze and we send you
the analyzed no no that's very
negotiation again broke because that was
already over the pre-competitive space
so those kind of learnings were very
important very important also to always
say what you're not going to talk about
so to start the conversation saying what
is what we agree that we disagree and we
are not going to record it you're not
gonna touch GMO is one of those topics
not gonna touch it because otherwise it
got lost in that kind of conversation
[Music]
[Music]
just to be clear I'm not saying that
self-sufficiency is the road to code we
put the scenarios out there it was the
President of Mexico who was elected by
the majority that said I want to go
self-sufficiency I I'm not saying that
is the right Road
that's the choice that was made I do
think there is a balance there it is not
about shutting one down and bringing
another one up it's about finding the
balance between those two and especially
look at the resilience so if you look at
the transportation system I'm scared
yeah cities yep absolutely
no and one of the biggest forces is
shipping companies I mean the big
shipping companies are the biggest force
against because that's their lifeline
right so I actually was afraid that some
of the broker big broker companies were
the ones that we're gonna say no we want
to keep bringing that grain to Mexico
actually they were not there they get
quite some conversations because they
see other business models they can adopt
adopting this new in this new system but
yes there are forces against but I do
think it's clear we need to be very
clear to say it is not shutting one down
and bringing one up it is creating the
resilience we require by balanced
interventions this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
cornell edu